(audience applaud)
I'm here with one of the stars of "Vacation Friends",
Meredith Hagner.
(audience cheer)
I'm clapping for myself, that's embarrassing,
I'm like...
I know, right?
Well, something that you're into though
is my biggest passion.
And I actually want to become your student right now.
You're going to take over the show
and lead me through your process
and teach us all a few things.
I feel like we're Chip and Joanna,
but we're, but, I think we're both Chip.
I'll be anything, you pick,
and I'll be the other one.
Okay, let's just both be Chip.
Okay, great, two Chips.
Two Chips is better than one.
All right.
I like that.
When you're shopping online, it can get intimidating.
I now do a lot of online shopping because as thrifters,
you would have to go to the actual places and I still do,
but there's new online opportunities, like never before.
So like when you're looking online, what are your tips?
I feel like I like to get a sense.
I feel like you can learn pretty quickly
if someone's crazy on email.
And I like to look at the photo and then kind of peek behind
to see if something's really disgusting
and be like, I'm going to pass.
Upholstery, just don't go there.
'Cause there's a 98% chance you will infect
your guests with bedbugs.
(Drew laughs)
And so, yeah, I like to just get an email sent.
I always bring a friend because you just don't know
what you're walking into.
Do you ever like, haggle?
Oh, all the time.
For the price?
Yeah, big haggler, but do it on the email
because you don't want to be there with someone
like someone's dog growling at you.
Like, how much?
No, you know, just don't.
I just haggled my way, like I just,
I'm surprising Ross with his new dressing room today
and I fully designed it and I went into this store
and I haggled the guy down and it just, it feels so good.
I'm so like, I know they're looking at me,
like I know who you, you know, just, I know,
I know they're looking at me like, oh no,
you are not haggling me, but I'm like,
I am a lifelong thrifter and that is part of the deal.
It's part of the gig.
(audience applaud)
Don't you feel powerful when you haggle?
All right, we're gonna go over to a little setup
and, Chip, you're going to take us through it.
Okay, Chip.
All right, Chip.
I am so excited.
(audience applaud)
So your show really helped with this obviously,
but it's pretty incredible.
So a fun thing to do is take, like, get vintage fabrics
really easy to turn it into like a little pillow like this.
This is all vintage fabric from Craigslist.
And then also you can do, I'll use it either
as like a tablecloth, sometimes a little runner.
Yep.
Little runner action.
Yeah, like a nice little sort of burlapy thing
can add a lot of texture.
As you see this table is sort of like threaded and glossy,
but the burlap changes that, it calms it down.
Okay, what's the next item?
Okay, next item is a lamp.
See this lamp?
Yes.
It was like 20 bucks.
It was very dated.
Oh, $20!
$20.
(audience applaud)
And it was a kind of lamp where you'd be,
you'd be like, ugh!
Why would anyone put this in their house?
But paint it white and then change the lampshade.
You can either do like a black matte thing,
which goes with this vibe where you could do something kind
of colorful and you know.
Really impressive lamp, really love that shade.
It's giving me like that dome shape.
Imagine this at night, like all moody.
I love this, okay.
What's the last item?
The side table, so this was like a $20-
$20!
(audience cheer)
Yes!
This is the thing, if you're not the handiest,
just enlist someone in your life
to do manual labor for you for free.
But you take the legs off and then you take these cylinders
from Home Depot, chop them up, glue them to the,
it sounds really, this is, and people are like, what!
No, no, Meredith like I'm literally
freaking out right now.
Isn't that cool?
You don't even understand.
Here's why, if you show the before picture,
you've changed the actual architecture of the table.
Instead of the legs being at the corner.
Yeah.
You've inset them.
And that actually will give you more depth.
Exactly.
That is really impressive.
Thanks.
(audience cheer)
Okay, God, I mean, you are just,
you are everything and more.
I love you.
I am inspired.
I, you know, you're my Chip.
You're my Chip.
I'm going to see you out and be like, Chip!
Oh, everybody, thank you, Meredith Hagner.
(audience cheer)
Watch "Vacation Friends".
Yeah, watch it, it's so fun.
(audience applaud)
If you wanna know what all the cool kids are watching
and you want to be super on point.
You watch "Search Party", all right?
And that'll be available on HBO Max.
Meredith, Chip.
Chip!
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)